welcome to three scary games
i hope you're having a lovely time hope
everything is going great for you
wherever you are i know exactly where
you are but
i hope that it's okay nonetheless no
trust me you don't want to look behind
you you want to look right at me
you want to look right behind me oh
weird seems like something's coming out
of that door back there
hope nothing shows up
you even want that to happen now would
we
welcome the boogeyman boogeyman is a
boogie
oh i
love that i love that
in oh yeah give me a taste of whatever
the hell we're watching
what the hell is it this is cool i'm
into this
i should protect myself before i start
relaxing
oh should i well i guess my front door
was just wide open
seems like it might have been bashed
down at some point probably not the best
thing in the world
i can't really see it oh [ __ ]
this plank will come in handy i didn't
even know i picked up a plank
i i mean did i do a plank or did i pick
up a plank i don't know what i got
do i i still need a hammer
oh oh i
oh install workbench repair house relax
and watch tv
and then i guess watch out for the
bogeyman
watch out for the big bogeyman
oh [ __ ]
oh well okay here i am downstairs
this is only moderately weird this is
only just just a little bit weird
alexia and i cranked up the volume a
little bit hopefully i didn't throw
everything off
if it did i'm sorry lixie and i'm
lexi please you don't need to be so
sassy with me i was just
i was just trying to make it better for
you man please please look [ __ ]
please you gotta understand i'm just
trying i'm trying to be a good youtuber
here
please stop where's the empty this time
[Music]
okay thank you thank you thank you
lindsay
okay what's through the woods here okay
ooh what am i looking at window
murder scene i would not know if there
were dead bodies in this room i would
not know
oh what the hell is that is that a clown
head oh it's a jack-in-the-box
i love jack-in-the-box i already have a
plank oh
good oh
i got a flashlight all right okay
very strange but uh
not a hundred percent sure what
the dealio is and usually i'm pretty oh
that seems like it would be very fun to
have that axe
that axed though oh my [ __ ]
here in my [ __ ] is this where i put
my hammer it is
it is where i put my hammer oh
crap oh crap oh no
come on jumping out there i am seeing
something out there oh no
oh no don't get me no don't get me
[Music]
thirsty please look shin why you gotta
be so spooky
wait a minute this wasn't on that side
before
was it nope
nope not dealing with that oh it must be
my tv
okay i know where another plank was it's
not my [ __ ] it's uh it's in the in
over here
okay got an another plank great yeah
yeah great
great who knew that these woods were
haunted by the one
and only lixian the most dangerous
beast of them all the evilest creature
to ever haunt
these woods the
lyxian is our plank down
looks like we got some writing going on
here
um i don't know where there would be a
key unless there was something like
inside the house that was another plank
or a key
it's this house change it did it
did
don't remember it being quite this
upside down before
very strange very interesting boy i'd
love another plank
would love another plank that'd be great
i guess i might need the flashlight to
be able to
see it i don't know why that would be a
thing but i'm just gonna guess that
that's a thing
i don't know where another plank would
be i have a funny feeling it's gonna be
like
in the chest for some reason and i gotta
find a key
i don't know why but that's just what i
suspect
maybe key in the well
this key will be useful great great
great good great i got that i did that
that's
good whoopsie poopsie a blank
good thing i put it in the whole chest
otherwise known as a basement otherwise
known as a chest in the basement it's
not a whole chest it's a
basement it's in the basement i got that
good
good good good good good good time to
hammer it lexi and i i'm doing i'm doing
it aren't i
i i'm appeasing you please oh
perfect there there we are all better
all better
time to relax and watch tv like the good
boy i
am oh oh big [ __ ] please
victory please i got a good boy
[Music]
next year oh
if only i knew how to prevent this you
know honestly
i haven't got a clue all right so that
was bogeyman
pretty good pretty good pretty weird
pretty good okay not too bad
all right moving on
i heard a noise behind me oh [ __ ] okay
this is the house
i don't like that don't like this here
don't like this here lexi
chapter one oh
scroll mouse forward to use lastly you
can examine items by pressing q
great press any key great this seems
like it's going to be a pure
classic haunted house experience
haunted by the ghost that is lixian of
course
you just came from outside i did i did i
did
awfully dark
spooky noises in the darkness
weird you can examine a lot of things in
this game
all right
well i hope this is my house
oh okay that's a classic
scare sound from slendy man
i remember slendy man
uh lies huh interesting um
i did not want to do it sorry oh well
that's okay
as long as you said sorry that's that's
really all that matters
appreciate it big preach on that one
everyone give a
round of appreciate oh
[ __ ] amnesia style baby
oh i use combine
okay can't reload yet probably because i
don't need to
oh interesting oh they put some work
into this
drag i don't like dragging open doors
like that
it's a little creepy ooh
i don't know what this is doing but i'm
doing it i'm just gonna start wailing on
pipes and levers what did i do
what did i do it's locked need to find a
key oh
get out of here oh they've got a whole
like
they've got a whole system in here
they've got the real deal
this game is legit trying
i appreciate that oh get out of here
think you can mess with me you cannot
oh [ __ ] i made my way to the power oh
[ __ ]
i did it power's back on baby
oh you think that you can mess with me
the answer is that you can hide
okay so i don't need to find a key
because i find my way around
trying to whoa all right thumb
okay now i need to find where doors are
get
this going context menu
no no context to that okay i don't need
a context to whatever that was all about
okay let me just go back in the thing
here this is
cool like it feels very amnesia
it really does and i think that might be
the feel that they're going for
a lot more interactivity than i'm used
to seeing in just basic horror games
oh [ __ ] there we go hello
hi how you doing hey what's up how are
you doing lexie and hey what's going on
here
whoa you're fast you're speedy
i didn't know you were so quick there
oh oh oh wait no wait no i sense a trap
i sense a trap
oh no i sense a trap oh no this is a
trap
i know a trap when i see it and this is
definitely a trap
oh this is so a trap oh
suck there is no end and there never
would be
oh good good oh
no
oh oh why you got a blue ball
me like that i was getting into it oh
god damn it
oh it was looking so good it was going
so
good it happens sometimes it happens
sometimes and that's just the way it is
but
gotta move on gotta move on
okay this is dark descendant i don't
know if this is one of my dark
descendants if it's darkiplier's
descendant or if it's something in
between but i'm going to play
jeez we're going fast
i'm sorry what just happened i have no
idea what went on i crashed my car
i think my daughter was in the in the
car there was like some kind of a rock
oh what
oh
okay interesting very
interesting i'm curious to see where
this is gonna go
i guess today's been the game of games
that are kind of decently put together
hope it doesn't end in a short
experience ooh
now this looks proper spooky i
guess i didn't need to read that
what oh oh it just disappeared when i
hovered over
hi my name is i've decided to start this
diary because today
my parents and i are going to move two
strange guys wearing very strange
clothes have come to our house and told
us we're going to start a new life
can't wait to see this house i love that
i just handle the paper every time i
read it just over and over again
okay we approach here uh do i want to
four keys to save your daughter
oh okay all right
where oh oh oh oh oh oh
what the hell was that what the hell is
going on
am i in the great beyond i feel like i'm
in the great beyond
what are the noises should i be afraid
of the noises okay
okay weird
weird okay so there must be like
uh here we go okay battery that's good
so that's for my flashlight but i don't
need it right now i don't want to waste
it
so there must be something here that i
need
right that's why i'm hearing jingle
jingles huh is there a key
here is one of you guys jingling your
keys in your grave
oh oh there oh yeah yeah oh thank you
for jingling
hello oh
it's my first week in this new house but
it doesn't feel very homely there are a
bunch of rooms that i'm not allowed to
go into and inside the house there's a
cemetery where i've been told the
previous owners used to bury your loved
ones in their pets
yeah a little creepy also it's in the
great beyond okay anyway
time to go back
well that's a problem that's what i
would call a problem
this is what i would call a problem this
is this is expressly a problem
oh i'm very sorry
oh i'm very sorry but uh what am i
supposed to do about that
oh i hope you're blind i hope you're
blind
i hope you're blind nice slow okay
you're not blind you're not blind you're
not blind
[Music]
okay that was some weird music
interesting musical selection there
buddy boo
okay can you come through here you
cannot
okay interesting interesting interesting
very interesting
okay so i guess i just gotta run past
you that's the only thing i can imagine
right
i'm going for it ah oh he's not here
anymore whoa
hello okay so i need to find three more
keys
is what i've guessed what the objective
is
arms oh
perfect great that's two down
two to go
i don't like these sounds
i don't like the sounds i do not like
the sounds
okay so i can hide in there in case he
comes back but so far it doesn't look
like he's a problem at the moment
oh [ __ ] today my daddy's brought a new
record the music is cool but it's in a
strange language that i can't understand
my parents started to dance in a weird
way while listening to music
they told me to join in which i did the
dance steps are kind of hard to memorize
but i think i'm starting to get them
since we moved here my parents haven't
stopped doing weird things
like dancing the freaks okay i heard a
door open but i just don't know where
the door is
i'll take that thank you today my daddy
brought home a man he didn't know he was
unconscious because he had been injured
in the woods and needed help as they put
him on one of the rooms i'm not allowed
to go into i haven't seen him yet i hope
he's okay
he's looking my daddy found him by the
way my mommy made dinner from a new
recipe and it was very tasty
oh yeah oh i bet oh i bet it was tasty
oh i bet it was so tasty did that
injured man get any of your tasty
delicious dinner
ah well i hope so
there he is okay no no you don't need to
come over you don't need to
is the thing you really don't need to
it's not
necessary i don't see where this door
opened i don't even have my light on i
don't need it
plenty of light in here anyway oh god
did it open the door to like the
courtyard or something
oh [ __ ] i bet it did oh no there is no
need
oh it's funny how there's no need for
you to come in here at home
yes go that way yeah you loser you loser
okay you suck yes i was right
i knew it i knew it's all along
okay i might need the flashlight here
let's get out let's get that let's get
out let's get down key
yes please thank you one more and i'm
good is there paper over here is there
something to read
oh paper it's been a month now but since
i became
ill my mommy gives me my medicine every
day and says that i will get better
eventually but that's not the case some
weird scabs
started to appear on my skin and my
voice is getting deeper every day my
daddy tells me that tomorrow some of his
friends will help me
we've to meet in the chapel i hope
they'll be able to help me
i hope that they'll be able to help me
okay weird am i to guess that this
monster is going to be
this like kid daughter maybe
i don't know fish seem kind of dead
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh god i didn't expect
you to be there
huh i'm gonna make a break for it i'm
gonna go for it
[Music]
i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine i'm
fine baby fine baby find baby you know
why boom
that's why
it ain't nothing it ain't no thing
you shove your own head up your own ass
and then kiss your ass goodbye that made
sense if you don't think about it too
much
where is this door oh it's over where he
is isn't it
okay he went in the menace
is he coming down here nah nice stupid
he's stupid
he's too stupid okay there we go there
there there
yeah yeah yeah yeah easy
four keys that was it right that's all i
need right
i think so i think so i think so right
four keys four
all right what what what no one
what what
what what i'm sorry
are you telling me that i went into the
room where my daughter was
and then immediately my daughter died in
a fire and then the monster came up and
[ __ ] slapped me
into the netherworld is that what you're
telling me
that's what happened i don't really know
what to say about that that was an
interesting experience
but that was three scary games let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below if you want to see
even more scary games dating back all
the way to 2012.
check the link in the description
there's a playlist with hundreds
of scary games for you and thanks again
and as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you